- Have you ever worked in a bar?
I have.
- I have. I have.
I feel like every
honestly successful woman
has at some point.
I started, and it was
funny cause I was like,
when I was in college in England,
I worked in a pub, and so I thought,
oh, this qualifies me
for working in a bar.
I'm a bartender, basically.
So pubs in England, you
do not have the same,
like, demands and you can
pour like a pint of Guinness.
But then I moved to LA.
I went to this place that
was on the Sunset Strip,
and I said, oh, I'm here to
apply for this job bartending.
And we're like, okay, cool.
So why don't you come in in
two days and just, you know,
make a bunch of your favorite cocktails?
Like, right.
So I go home. I'm living
with roommates at the time.
I've never made a cocktail in my life.
I'm living with roommates at the time
and I go and buy "Bartending for Dummies."
And I literally think
that somehow in 48 hours,
I'm going to learn how to be Tom Cruise.
Like, I just think that's
just what's gonna happen.
- That's awesome.
- So I'm like, okay, a Manhattan,
or I just try to pick the
simplest cocktail I can,
practice on my roommates,
and everybody just sort
of humors me with like,
okay, yeah, this is great.
And so I go back to this place.
It was actually BOA Steakhouse
on Sunset, on Sunset Strip,
but it has, like, a bar section.
And I make this drink and it's god awful.
And I'm literally, like, measuring it out,
trying to look really cool
and smooth and like shaking.
And then at the end of
it, he's like, cool.
So, waitressing.
- So you're going to take
the drinks to the tables.
Awesome.
- Yeah. Yeah.
- Were you a better waitress?
- I mean, I made up for in
enthusiasm what I lacked
in punctuality, I would say.
I was like, my favorite...
I worked... I actually have
so many choice experiences
from the Cat and Fiddle
all in my run-up to -
- Oh, the Cat and Fiddle.
- Booking my first acting gigs.
I know, it's not there
anymore, but it was on Sunset
and so much fun.
And it was like, I
think one of the nights,
it was like, it was pre Oscar night,
and Adrien Brody was at a table
with a bunch of really amazing people.
And they all ordered Hendricks, Hennessy,
something that was expensive.
I don't know.
And simple by the way.
And it took me so long to bring it
that by the time I brought
probably the wrong drinks,
they had all left
because they had to be
somewhere, obviously the Oscars.
And they, but left me
a hundred dollar tip,
and I had never even brought
their drinks for them.
So I'm like, okay.
So I owe Adrien Brody a
shot or a hundred bucks.
- Either way, either way.